[Music]
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
the content of this program is to
provide nutritional education only this
program is not meant to take the place
of your primary care physician the FDA
requires us to let you know that our
products are not meant to treat prevent
diagnose or cure any diseases as an
empowered individual you have options
available we are honored to have one of
the founding fathers of epigenetics here
to guide us with the best options to
obtain or maintain Optimal Health Dr
Joel Wallach welcome to daily with Doc
and Becca
foreign
[Music]
thank you
foreign
[Music]
okay all right let's open up the door
hello hello
YouTube Hello Rumble hello Facebook so
glad to see you here and hello to all of
you who are joining us live on daily
with Doc my name is Becca dukes and I am
the hostess of this program and so
honored to be the hostess of this
program as
seven years ago I never would have
dreamed it never ever would I have
dreamed this but a few people
took the fact that I had great results I
had some enthusiasm they shared their
belief in me and I have just been able
to take that belief and share it with
others and just soar myself and help
others soar as well so it is absolutely
fabulous folks what happens when you
give your body what it needs so that
your body can Thrive your mind works you
get function back into every cell of
your body and then you just say okay
this is what I want you set your
intentions and Bam make it happen folks
we are empowered individuals and this
program
is
providing empowering information that
will help you also
be able to claim better things for
yourself especially if you're dealing
with health challenges if you're not
dealing with Health Challenge health
challenges you are very blessed
and this information is still for you to
help you stay in your optimal best again
you are tuning into daily with Doc
and for those of you who are joining us
we just want to make sure you know that
the content of this program is for
educational purposes only it is not
meant to take the place of your primary
care physician and our products are not
meant to diagnose treat cure any
diseases but folks when you take this
information and utilize it not just
listen but hear
and then take action
it's like garbage and garbage out you're
gonna put garbage in you're gonna get
garbage out you're going to put the good
stuff in you're going to get good stuff
out it just cause an effect and we're
going to be learning about some other
causes and effects here in this program
today on daily with Doc now if you're
out on YouTube or Facebook or Rumble and
you want to join us here live in our
Zoom room please go ahead and come on
over we are at Daily with Doc zoom.com
and of course it's only from Monday
through Friday
noon Pacific to 12 50 p.m okay so we
want to make sure that if you're going
to join us you're not joining us five
minutes after or right at the end and if
you are here with us make sure that you
raise your hands so that we can call
upon you if you have questions for Dr
Wallach
about yourself you're somebody you love
somebody in your community
or even for those of you who have tried
the products and you're getting great
results like many many many many many
many many of us
um go ahead and feel free to share a
testimonial as well so with without any
further Ado it is my privilege and honor
to present to you Dr Joel Wallach now Dr
Wallach is a lifetime learner he has
taken so many things so many events that
have led him into
great opportunities
and even though he had a lot of
adversity coming at him a lot of things
trying to stop him he did not give up
and I personally am thankful that he is
a fighter and a lifetime learner because
all that he has done has contributed so
greatly to my life and where I am today
that I can't say thank you enough Dr
Wallach
thank you for being here with us on
daily with Doc
I know that you have some exciting
things to share with us today so why
don't you go ahead thank you so much
Rebecca and thank you so much team and
of course we couldn't do this without
the whole team and
um this is growing because we are
providing useful functional information
and it's Universal
uh it's not a
um which I say it's not a racial thing
it's not a financial thing it's
Universal it doesn't matter what country
you're from what race of people you are
uh it's like crazy is so simple
the good Lord made us to live well
beyond 120 it's been proven here in
modern times uh the record in the
industrialized world is a French one by
the name of Gene Calment
and she died in 1997 at 122 years 164
days that's not bad okay that's pretty
good and so that's a good thing to shoot
for 120 years is what the Bible says and
manager shall be 120 years
and Gene kilman prove that okay and so
it's one of those things where
you have to do your part stay away from
the bad stuff and do the good stuff and
this is why we come up with so many
books some CDs and DVDs and we have
these programs and zooms and
Communications and meetings and things
to get that information out there it's
the the information is too valuable just
to keep to ourselves
so we throw it out there to as many as
we can and we'll save as many as we can
we want to make Humanity thrive
and it takes a lot of effort to do that
you just can't sit there and you know
eat all the bad stuff and do all the bad
stuff and expect to maximize your Health
and Longevity
so that said one thing I want to do now
uh today is introduce a new book it's
one of a series of books that's coming
out I think there's like 20 books in the
series
um each book is into a group of animals
this first one here is primates okay
seemed appropriate and prime age is a
wonderful book and this is for
um individuals who like animals this is
for individuals who are studying biology
this is for
um pet stores this is for veterinarians
um let's see here this is for
libraries in medical schools
naturopathic schools Chiropractic
schools Veterinary Schools Biology
Schools
um schools of
Pharmacy okay all these people need this
information on animals because this is
where the laboratory work is done
because at the end of the study
oftentimes you know they'll have a
hundred monkeys they might just either
spread them out among zoos or they might
just destroy them okay you can't do that
to people so it's important that we have
these various animals all around the
world and the first one is primates
now I want you to start out in this book
primates go to page 206 okay page 206
and why do I say certain out in page
206. well that's because this is the
beginning of the story
okay with my real serious work
with primates at the Yorkies primate
Center in Emory University
um Atlanta Georgia
1976 okay I had finished my 10-year
study the big um 20-something million
dollar Grant uh where I did my 20 000
autopsies my thesis sells for twenty
five thousand dollars each it was picked
up by WB Saunders uh one of the biggest
medical publishing houses
and um and you know I got a little
um royalty every time they'd sell one of
those books they went to that book at
twenty five thousand dollars each it
went to libraries it went to
universities went to big biology study
groups that we went all over the world
and in various languages and everything
and so is is quite the thing and of
course
um did on top season over 454 species of
animals plus humans
and
the again books
uh sold the new books package not opened
not written on or tweaked on the page
Corners
um for twenty five thousand dollars each
so we we came out with the book
uh epigenetics which is a new science to
take the place of epigenetics takes a
place of genetics there are no exactly
transmitted diseases
and there are no
um autoimmune diseases and so the book
ABC excels for twenty five dollars each
now 25 000 but 25 each and we sell a lot
of them because it's a summary of the
twenty five thousand dollar
research project okay now
right now this book
um it starts out on page 206 and talks
about
the study I did it again is your keys
primate Center
because we found the first non-human
case of cystic fibrosis supposed to be
one of the most terrible birth defects
in humanity and I sent slides to five
different medical schools I didn't tell
them the slides were from monkeys I just
said I think this is Cynthia Bros what
do you think they all wrote back on
their letterhead saying yeah this is a
classic example of City Barbosa's I sent
him samples of pancreas liver lungs
um
heart that kind of stuff it all came
back silver bro says and I told them it
was from a monkey this is probably the
first
diagnosed monkey in a colony
um at the European Primary Center or
anywhere else in the world
that had been diagnosed with silica
roses
and then I wrote up my paper because
we're going to present it a big National
event here in the United States
and they said what's this walk what do
you mean it's not genetic no it's not
genetic it's a simple nutritional
deficiency and we can I can make you you
want a thousand baby monkeys with city
of roses I'll make them for you in three
months time and they fired me some early
he's inspired me the volunteer sniffing
glue everybody knows there's a big
genetic birth effect
and
they which I say sent the word around
not to hire me because I was crazy and
so I couldn't get a job anywhere else
and so I think okay what am I going to
do here so I started going to these
various events and trade shows and I
learned about naturopathic doctors never
heard them before and say okay I'm going
to school and I got a job teaching at
the naturopathic college and CNM
National College of naturopathic
medicine up in Portland Oregon and I
said you know I might as well since I'm
here I might as well go ahead and take
the courses so I'm going to get some
credit for some of my courses and
veterinary medicine and and so forth
um let's uh go for getting a degree in
nature Panic medicine which I did in the
naturopathic doctor and so then I began
to treat people okay because I knew many
many things that doctors didn't know
because of all my work in animals and on
the autopsies I did and so forth and to
make a long story short
um there's
again at the End of This Book 2006
um excuse me 206 to 215 206 to 215. and
this segment at the end of the book goes
through my experience of discovering the
first non-human case of cisibrosis
getting it you know agreed upon is
that's what it was and also all the
newspaper articles that the Yorkies
Primary Center at first sent out where
we found the first non-human cases of
cystic fibrosis we got we're going to
probably have laboratory animals and
we're so excited about that
and then when I told them that it was
not a genetic thing it was a simple
nutritional efficiency I could make as
many monkeys with City roaches they
wanted this when they fired me so I went
back to school and became a physician
and I realized how backwards the medical
system was when it came to birth defects
and there are no birth defects that are
caused by bad genes or no birth defects
are caused by autoimmune problems okay
they're all caused I'd say 98 or Cosmic
social efficiencies and a couple of
percentage points are caused by toxins
that the mother might come in contact
with you know early in pregnancy and
early pregnancy
and so this is something that again I
want people to start by reading because
you know you start reading the first
couple of chapters you're talking about
anesthesia monkeys for surgery and
um what to feed monkeys it could get
boring by the third chapter you just say
I'll throw a style finish it later you
never get back to it and so that's why I
want you to start
with the
study that started the whole thing which
is the study on city of roses in the
rhesus monkeys from yerky's Primary
Center oh my gosh and and so
um you know a lot of microscopic
pictures of the tissues all the damage
and everything so this is
um which they say will get you started
then you're going to make sure that
every pet store in America has this book
every zoo in America in the world has
this book every research colony okay
that has monkeys every teaching County
that has monkeys every every institution
as monkeys were watching Behavior will
have this book in their library and it's
maybe even required reading okay for the
courses
that's because there are cousins
um we get a lot of the diseases they
have they get a lot of diseases we have
okay and so it's a lot easier to study
you know a thousand monkeys
okay then it is to try and round up a
thousand people who want to sacrifice
your time and energy and and and so
forth
to be part of such a study
and um so this is one of those things
where we've accumulated an honest amount
of information
and if you don't have a pet monkey or if
you do if they have a squirrel monkey
okay you have a woolly monkey you have a
rhesus monkey you know you can have all
these different monkeys okay you're not
going to have a chimpanzee usually at
home you're not going to have a gorilla
at home okay but they have a Zeus and
the zoo bookstore should have this book
to sell and help support the projects of
the zoo you know when you buy 10 of them
you get a nice discount
and they're only 22.99 each new
okay I'm very very excited about this
um and I have to thank
the Liddell who's the editor
um of this book and he noticed that you
know that we really weren't telling the
story about city of roses so he
insisted and put in the history of the
physical brosis so that people would
understand
why the primary colonies in the world
are so important
and so with that said I'm going to turn
this back over to Rebecca well Dr
Wallach
this is pretty incredible and people are
thinking well why is he talking about
primates on on a show that is promoting
human health and wellness something that
Dr Wallach said and it it sounds
it sounds weird I wouldn't want anybody
to you know experiment on animals and
create any type of disease but it goes
to prove
that that garbage and garbage out
you take the nutrients out of the diet
and your health is going to go in a
direction that coincides with Dr
wallach's research
and what has been found when nutrients
are deficient specific diseases occur
and Dr Wallach it just totally makes so
much sense to me
and the fact that it's not more common
knowledge well one of the things that
you know when I talk to somebody say I
have a health problem I want to talk to
you about Dr Walton you say okay well
first of all tell me do you take any
vitamins meals I take vitamin C every
day well what about the other 89
essential nutrients no no I eat well
okay you know they're in trouble right
away
okay because plants do not make minerals
and minerals make up two-thirds of the
90 essential nutrients plants do not
make minerals plants make vitamins and
amino acids and fatty acids but they
don't make minerals nutritional minerals
are not a kernel uniform blanket around
the trust of the ears they turn in veins
like gold and silver
and this is why we have so many problems
and you'll see this country has a high
rate of disease X and this country has a
high rate of disease xx and so on
because they're missing these nutrients
in the soil and they're just quote
eating well
and my my favorite sad story
is Bruce Lee Who was the
the
which is existential okay he was the it
was like the icon of Health right he was
the icon of Health he was considered the
fitness Guru by every country in the
world he was always invited to speak to
graduating classes all over the world he
was you know speaking to uh sports teams
all over the world Olympic teams and
professional teams professional athletes
and so forth and he died at 32 years of
age of a heart attack
now why would that happen well that's
because he was only supplementing with
one mineral he was 59 Sharp he was told
by doctors not to waste his money on
Bottoms will just eat well he'd get
everything you need
but he had some muscle cramps so he took
magnesium
and then he did use the brewers yeast to
get B vitamins other than that he just
quote ate well
and that's why he died at 32 because
he's sweating and sweat is not just
water I guarantee he was hydrating with
high quality and high priced bottled
water
it might have even been that mineral
sparkling water doctor might have been
sparkling boy which is even worse but it
neutralizes stomach acid so you cannot
absorb minerals or digest food
so yeah it's one of those things where
everybody should get a hold of that book
Dr walek's cooking without the bad foods
and 300 pages of of uh safe recipes and
cooking methods plus a good food bad
food list in there okay very important
Dr likes cooking without the bad foods
and then
um get a hold of
Dead Doctors Don't Lie get a hold of
heavy genetics get a hold of
the Wallach Revolution
it'll hold a walk Revolution and of
course another one of my favorite books
I don't talk about enough is Hell's
Kitchen because it goes from the
transfer of Hell's Kitchen goes from
wood and Coles Fuel and we're putting
the wood ashes and coal ashes in our
Gardens our vegetables will suck up
those minerals we would eat those
vegetables we get the meals that way and
we would also
put the what ashes and coal ashes into
our food as a spice we get minerals that
way but when we went to electricity at
three o'clock in the afternoon Monday
September 4th and this whole story of
the transition is in this book Hell's
Kitchen
and that book right there should be a
Nobel Prize because every doctor missed
it just eat well you get everything eat
well we gave up
all of our mineral supplements when we
gave up wood ashes and coal ashes and we
went to electricity electricity don't
get me wrong electricity was great for
manufacturing great for an industry
but more people have died
because of electricity doesn't have
any nutrition doesn't have any minerals
then the heavy vitamins had nothing it's
an energy source for machinery
okay is is what electricity is and this
this transition
boom thousands and thousands and
thousands of years of wooden coal is
fuel to electricity and nobody was
prepared for it and being a pathologist
and doing over 500
450 something autopsies was when this
book came out but I've done a lot of
autopsy since then
okay and it's one of those things where
the the the mission is to get that
information out to as many people as
possible
because you cannot get what you need
just by eating well
you cannot just take vitamin C and maybe
some
um maybe some niacin because you like
that flush and think you're going to get
somewhere no that doesn't cut it hey if
you want a tropical vacation folks
just pop
if it's all you need
yeah no so you Dr Wallach you had
mentioned what this book was written
with 450 autopsies that's 450 plus
species of autops yes yes that's correct
454 species yes it's 20 just that one
study was twenty thousand autopsies
so there you've got a lot of um a lot of
slides a lot of
experience
on that table
of looking at things like no one else
has doctor that's true that's true yes
32 000 autopsies for 154 species and
the average pathologist usually deals
with one species you know be a human
pathologist they might see a few dogs or
something like that from a lab at the
hospital or to medical school or you
might you know see a you know a couple
of rabbits or something like that
but they didn't see all these species of
animals from all over the world getting
the same diseases now if they were
genetic disease in humans how did a
wombat get it how did a whale get it a
bear a bear and one of my favorite
stories is
um out of 10 12 years ago one of the our
biggest problems in in the aquariums the
big aquariums in the countries all over
the world
um all of the dolphins of every species
of dolphins and whales were dying of
congestive heart failure so I studied
them on the autopsies table and figured
out
they're all eating the same kind of fish
and the fish had an enzyme in it that
killed one particular vitamin and in
laboratory animals we knew that there's
one particular vitamin deficiency caused
congestive heart failure so we switched
the type of fish that they were eating
to a different species of fish that did
not have that enzyme we gave him the 90
essential nutrients plus extra
okay of that one vitamin and you can
read it in the book
um I don't want people just running to
the grocery store and buying one vitamin
because you need the 90 right
so I'm selling now no more deaths from
congestive heart failure and all the
dolphins and whales
and so when we give somebody a program
for heart disease we give them the
healthy and heart pack which has that
nutrient in there but we also will throw
in
even if they don't have congestive heart
failure we'll throw in the distress
capsules
okay now you might think oh that's
because if you have stress no the D
stress capsules are called that because
we didn't want to
um
which I say drive people to get that one
nutrient
um in case it had congestive heart
failure so when you have heart failure
you need all 90 essential nutrients get
rid of all the bad stuff maximize
absorption stop all the inflammation
and take an addition
to other things ultimate daily classic
tablets for circulation the details
capsules okay to prevent and reverse
congestive heart failure it's one of
those things where
we want people we want everybody to live
to be Beyond a hundred
and not have any health issues it's
doable
we do this in animals we maximize their
longevity by giving them all these
nutrients and we control their their
diet they can't run around eat bad stuff
because they're in a cage or they're in
a zoo or they're on a uh one of these um
a big aquariums kind of things so we're
controlling every piece of their
environment
of what they eat what they drink and so
forth and we're adding so many healthy
years to the lives of these captive
animals that people cannot complain oh
those animals can live to be 50 years
old and they're all down at three and
four years of age in captivity no no we
don't have any of that anymore because
we're giving them all the known
essential nutrients the same way from
the best of we're maximizing their
longevity and health we are making them
live longer and healthier in in zoos
than they are out in the wild
all right thank you so much for that Dr
Wallach and then folks you can get Dr
wallach's books at
drjwalik.com that is d r j
wallick.com you invite all of his
Publications we're getting the primates
book up on the website today so if
you're wanting to get that go ahead and
call the number on the website and they
can get that ordered for you or wait
till tomorrow and you can order it
through the website that's drj
wallick.com
Dr Wallach we have some questions
um several questions so the first one
that I want to go to I want to go way
far south Dr Wallach
and I am going to ask my friend Douglas
to join us here he has some questions
for you so Douglas
go ahead and unmute yourself I'll bring
you on camera as well
and welcome to daily with doc thank you
very much Rebecca good morning Doc and
hello it's so nice to see you again okay
now is this
I've been around quite some time I'm
from Brisbane Australia Australia okay
in Australia yeah I'm in Aussie yeah and
just about 10 years ago I went through a
problem with romantic cell non-hodgkin
swim for women
um over the period of time of course
I've been on your products and
everything that I've been on of course
has kept me healthy all the way through
but minus one faux pas
um currently my age is 65 my weight is
around 52 kgs
I'm at 52 gauge these would be around
about the 90 to 90 to 100 pounds
um
my height is around five foot seven
and just recently as of last week I was
diagnosed with lung cancer
with a possibility
with the possibilities of asbestosis as
well okay were you a smoker
Once Upon a Time year stock I was okay
did you work in a factory
never did Doc
okay did they take a biopsy or they just
diagnosed by an x-ray
uh diagnosed this was diagnosed by CT
scan
and what the doctors noticed was there
was a coroner on the the head of one of
them to 29 25 29 by 25 by 13 mil
um that they're looking at at the moment
and so there's a mass in one lung it's a
mess in one lump with the two asbestosis
lumps on either side of the the cluster
okay do they recommend removing that
lung
I know they at this current stage now
just waiting for some final details to
come through
um the
the larger part of the the growth at the
moment is almost touching the pleura
which is a bit of a concern that they're
having yeah yeah we wouldn't we don't
want it to break through there okay now
yeah the first thing we want to do is
support your immune system your immune
system to be your best friend here
yeah and say a hundred pounds 110 pounds
somewhere in there once you get rid of
all the bad foods no fried foods no
processed Meats yep we're talking about
you know no nitrates in ham and bacon
and bologna and salami and
pepperoni and hot dogs all that stuff's
got to go uh absolutely uh no
um let's see here no oils okay no salad
dressing no cooking oils I like to use
just lemon wedges and squirt lemon juice
on my salad I also yeah so I learned
that trick from you doc yep and then I
also want you to stay away from gluten
no wheat and right around oats or no
such things as good uh oats the gluten
and oats is called gliadin sometimes
it's still gluten and then you also need
to get rid of Buckwheat buckwheat
pancakes were quite common when I was a
kid
um but buckwheat has a substance in it
called fago Pyrenees f-a-g-o Pyrenees
which are worsened
so you got to get rid of Buckwheat and
then no sugar
which drives cancer or no carbonated
drinks okay
um and that includes
um
drinks you know with no uh nothing in
them diet drinks you can't and also
carbonated water can't have it okay
because it neutralizes stomach acid now
100 pounds I want you to have one
healthy brain and heart pack per month
one healthy brain and heart pack one has
215 nutrients in it the core nine year
is still in there yeah half a dose of
everything twice a day
and he also wants to get two bottles a
month of our MSM take three of breakfast
treat lunch at dinner time and they're
going to support and promote manage
repair of cartilage ligaments tendons
connective tissue discs between bone
matrix including bone marrow where your
white those are made your wife of the
cells or your best friend they're your
Cavalry they're going to go and kill and
eat the cancer cells right yeah yeah so
yeah so yeah you want the the
um uh
MSM so you get that to to build up more
white blood cells and antibodies you
could kill and eat the cancer cells and
then let's see here we also want you to
make sure that you're getting the
uh I I would go with the colloidal
silver
yep it was a collateral silver uh two
drivers fell under your tongue
you wake up in the morning say 10 15
minutes for breakfast lunch and dinner
and then two drivers fall under your
tongue before bedtime I do that okay and
it's going to kill bugs where you might
get a secondary infection which is quite
common when you have cancer because that
means that your immune system is low and
so you don't want to do that
and
um let's see here
uh
Becca anything else you would do to help
um
the immune system you mentioned oxy body
Dr Wallach I did not say oxy body but he
could take oxy body could take a full
ounce of that twice a day oxy body on an
empty stomach
okay take it before yeah you take it
before say say 15 20 minutes before you
eat
okay yeah five Peabody that's good
because when you raise oxygen cancer
cells don't like that
yeah okay yeah okay we'll keep us
informed let us know what's going on
here and you know we'll kind of walk
through this with you okay thank you
very much details you know from the
doctors
yeah well as soon as I get that through
doc I'll I'll send a message through to
you as well too thank you so much folk
and God bless you you're part of the
family sir thank you thank you very much
sir thank you all right thank you Doug
you are in our thoughts and prayers you
do amazing things down down yonder Down
Under on under um and promoting Dr
wallach's message and folks it doesn't
keep us from getting sick but what it
does is it gives us a fighting chance
that if something ever does occur
we can fight even harder and have hope
that there is
positive outcomes right Dr Wallen yeah
we have access to information and tools
raw materials
um things you can't get in many other
places and so we're you know we
purposely keep everything
which I say
um reasonably priced
we don't try to be outrageous we're just
making sure that everybody has access to
everything they need
and if you remember you pay the
wholesale prices you get an auto ship I
will pay the shipping that'll save you a
lot of money
well and one thing I I do want to point
out Dr Wallach is if you are
looking for something cheap
what you're going to find isn't going to
work
and it takes quality raw ingredients
which do cost money to create a quality
product that your body can actually
utilize
so please folks everybody that is
listening to this realize you are
valuable you are worth the investment
and this is the greatest investment you
could ever make into anything with life
you can have tons and tons of money but
if you don't have the health to be able
to enjoy it
or cut your life short because of a
nutrient deficiency
then what is all that money worth
nothing
you are worth millions your health is
worth even more so please please please
if nobody has told you today that you
are valuable you are worth time you are
worth taking that extra effort and
making sure that you are giving your
body what it
needs
now so much what it wants because when
we're nutrient deficient our body wants
different things that are not going to
be so healthy because it is starving and
it's looking for nutrition so we're
going to have those cravings
you are valuable and you are definitely
worth taking a look and giving us 90
days on Dr wallach's protocols and the
products that he's been so active in
formulating with an amazing team of
formulators
you will feel the difference
I did
so and of course my personal Drive is to
rent Earth's effects in kids
and that's that's where I goes brand
birthday fiction kids uh there are no
gently transmitted birth defects there's
no autoimmune birth defects they're all
caused by as a 90 Cosmic nutritional
efficiencies maybe two percent caused by
a toxin and the mother was exposed to
early in pregnancy
and so with that knowledge and the
access to these nutrients
I'm the guy who think about it I'm the
guy who got rid of physical brosis I'm
the guy who got rid of mustard this
weekend thank God Jerry Lewis knew it
before he died they put a gag order on
him when he brought him the information
said we found the college financial care
of much and the most just the
association
fired him put a gag order on him so he
couldn't say anything to anybody and
actually uh sit down and tell us how it
was supposed to be the next day and he
had raised 2.6 billion with a B 2.6
billion dollars on his Telethon but it
was his
passion to find a cure
for most history that got me involved in
it and we did find the Cure okay so he
was so proud and happy about that even
though he couldn't be sort of at the
front of the the story
and because he was he was gag ordered by
the Massachusetts Association
and Dr Wallach one thing that I really
appreciate but what Ryan did and putting
together primates is in that section I
think it what was it 206 to 2 15 15.
he even includes articles
that were posted in the newspapers about
your findings and you being fired
so it's documented folks
um your news release from Emory
University
so it's it's documented and if you need
proof there you go something that's
tangible something that we can get our
own hands on as Dr Wallach has done some
amazing work and our job
is to get it out there because this work
was done decades ago
it is beyond time
yeah it's beyond time to get this
knowledge worldwide
and in the hands and ears
of others so they too can take a stance
in creating healthier communities Dr
Wallach
folks if you're here with us in the live
zoom and you'd like to ask Dr Wallach a
question please feel free to find that
raise hand option in the zoom menu if
you're out on YouTube or rumble or
Facebook I can see the ones from YouTube
trying to figure out why I can't see the
ones from the others but
um I have some amazing co-hosts that are
watching those as well and as we have a
commenter question come up we were we'll
do our best to get to all of the
comments and questions that are
presented during our show and then do
responses to those on the replays so if
you're watching this
for the first time and somebody
specifically invited you to watch this
program make sure that you get back with
them and say thank you so much for
sharing that with me because folks they
took the time they cared enough and they
found and see that value in you to take
the time to share this information with
you now we do have Marilyn who has her
hand up and Marilyn go ahead and unmute
yourself
hello yes uh say I've been taking
youngevity's products for a couple years
now and I've always noticed that they
mentioned co-factors can you explain a
little bit about them and why they are
like non-proteins
okay well cofactors
um for instance vitamin D3 is a cofactor
when you're talking about absorbing
calcium
okay
um it is
this is not complicated but it's
complicated
for instance we have programs for over
600 different health issues
you have 5 000 products
some of them are liquid some is the same
product could be a powder a liquid a
chewable because people like chewables
people like the liquids some people like
the powders and so you have to provide
them in the forms of people will take
them and utilize them on a regular basis
they don't like
the liquids are not going to take them
okay and of course why did why were they
why were the British people called
limeys
now they didn't know this but they
started the whole thing on
supplementation okay in modern times now
before that it was salt it was sea salt
but the next one
was limes and they gave Sailors limes
just to have something to have you know
on a three-month trip across the ocean
so they gave them some limes they
noticed that the sailors that ate the
limes didn't get scurvy and they didn't
know what was in the limes that made
prevented Scarborough and cured security
but they knew there was something in
there so all of the British people began
to eat limes at home or on the ships and
this that and the other and people they
were working with around the world and
that's where the British were called
limeys because
they were they lived and breathed limes
because they knew that somehow there was
something in it that prevent it and
cured scurvy there's nothing else that
would do that other than limes and so
these are the sort of things that you
have to know the histories of what's
going on here and so
um you can appreciate uh why people
suffered they died from a simple vitamin
C deficiency they die of scurvy
okay but once they started eating limes
on a regular basis
no more scurvy
is it was that simple and so
um this is why I think people still
today vitamin C is a big thing
all over the place there's
what they say
there's not
89 other nutrients you need to have
90 essential nutrients but everybody
knows about vitamin C
because obscurving the story was told
over and over and over because there's a
whole shiploads of sailors would die of
scurvy
okay and so it was a big deal for you
know a couple hundred years ago to 500
years ago that that sort of period of
time when transatlantic and
trans-pacific shipping was done suddenly
now people were not getting fresh
vegetables and things like that
and they weren't getting oranges and
lemons and limes and so forth or fruit
and berries and so on
and so once they figured out there was
something in limes
and that is vitamin C and so this that
was the beginning of vitamin
supplementation was this was the uh when
scurvy went away when people ate limes
so it's a cold factor a vitamin A
mineral or is it something different or
is it a combination of the two it could
be a cofactor for says vitamin D helps
you absorb calcium
um calcium works best when you have the
um
uh
cartilage and ligaments and tendons the
connective tissue you have the
um cofactor of the
sort of
bone matrix okay if you're eating
calcium you don't have any place to put
it you're not going to build your bones
you need to have
the cofactors of the bone matrix okay
collagen peptides for the calcium we put
on and so it's kind of like a substrate
I'm sorry would you say it's kind of
like a substrate depending on
it could be paint on top of a house you
know to prevent the wood from rotting
yeah you understand what I'm saying okay
people tar paper under the shingles so
that there's more protection against the
roof leaking and yeah you know a
co-factor is or exactly what it says
there's something that goes along with
your primary
um concern okay goes along with your
primary tool your primary
substance
which may be wood but the wood will last
longer if you paint it so paint is a
cofactor to extend the life of that wood
beam or something like that okay okay
thank you
all right so Dr wellex like things
synergistically work better together
so I know calcium you you had mentioned
vitamin D3 but there's also strontium
and Boron and phosphorus and manganese
and magnesium all of these things when
you put them together in the right
ratios which your formulators have
figured out can do some amazing things
because I had taken each and every one
of those individually well not everyone
I didn't know about boron and strontium
but I took the others individually and I
wasn't feeling any difference I still
hurt all over I still had
limited Mobility
until I started on your formulations Dr
Wallach and I felt the difference
so let's go to the next town that is up
Dr Wallach
and we have Brian Brian go ahead and
unmute I'm going to bring you on camera
with us
and welcome welcome from the other side
of the United States of America
how are you today Brian oh delightful
delightful uh very uh really enjoyed the
start off of the book with the primates
I worked at Pfizer and was one of the
very few contractors with primate with
the vivarium lab pass and so there you
go I'm looking forward to reading that
hmm
um uh thank you all thank you Rebecca
and and uh everybody helping and thank
you DOC for your service and uh hear you
on Coast to Coast as well and always and
intrigued so thank you George is
wonderful
well that you are wonderful too for all
the service of time
um I know you like to jump right to it
so I have yeah we only have a few
moments here so let's get to it right
um sorry uh so uh we have a female who
is 48 years old
she's five foot seven
recently overweight
going up to 165.
and so
um she got uh
um uh she was born with a uh atrial
septic defect at the age at the age when
she was born and it was repaired at the
age of two
so atrial septal defects sorry if I had
that wrong okay she developed
scarcio-dosis in the age of in the 30s
and she also got Hardware in her right
hand from a tragic accident
and uh over the last two years uh she's
been having to go to Brio and Mona Lucas
for managing the scarcio doses
sorry
and um the other thing that's new is she
now is critically low in D
and has had low white blood cells
all right yeah so her bone marrow's not
happy because as for the white blood
cells are made okay and it's interesting
because he's in the southern in the
island somewhere
oh we're in the New England oh New
England well okay maybe that's why I
should get enough vitamin D okay
165 pounds she's getting rid of all the
bad stuff she's getting a hold of that
book Dr Wallace cooking without the bad
foods 300 pages of of
um safe recipes and cooking things uh
absolutely no fried foods no processed
meat no air frying no deep frying no pan
frying no that kind of stuff no oils of
any kind I like lemon wedges and that
kind of stuff and then if they require a
creamy dressing for a particular salad I
like to use yogurt okay okay
and then
um then there's
um gluten no wheat no butter and oats
there are no such things as gluten-free
oats even the gliadin is still gluten
and then no buckwheat no fago Pyrenees
phagopyreines don't have gluten in them
but they are more terrible than gluten
and then no sugar and no
um carbonated drinks even the diet one's
got to go and no carbonated water
because they neutralize stomach acid
then everybody should be using our
seasoned salt from Australia or our
Himalayan salt from the Himalayan
Mountains it has 28 other minerals in
there including the sodium chloride
and salt was one of the first
some supplements nutritional supplements
in the history of humanity okay and when
you did something good and people really
respected you and it was a blessing
something you did you were the salt of
the earth
because everybody knew salt was very
very good and required for life so you
if somebody gave you the compliment of
being the salt of the earth they really
respected you okay
and then of course
um she needs to have an 165 pounds in
order to have two healthy brain and
heart packs per month two Health packs a
month a full Dosa it has 215 nutrients
in each of those healthy brand hard
packs the 90 essential nutrients are
still the core I wanted to have a full
dose of everything twice a day
already have the MSM two bottles a month
of MSM so you take three at breakfast
lunch at dinner time they'll support and
promote maintenance repair cartilage
ligaments tendons connective tissue disk
between bone rate upon itself including
the bone marrow to make white blood
cells and antibodies and platelets and
red blood cells okay and then the septal
defect did they fix that surgically
earlier in her life or she's still yeah
okay fix this serves okay okay then I
also want her to have our let's see here
um
I want her to have our
I think huh
you got it all yeah because she's gonna
get the selenium you know in the healthy
brand hard pack okay so she'll have two
bottles of that so she can take a full
dose three of those twice a day okay the
selenium and then um I wanted to use our
rebound or sports drink or rebounds for
shrink uh she can have
um two servings a day of that
um and I'd say before
two o'clock in the afternoon want a
breakfast one at noon as late as two in
the afternoon and of course we have the
capsules we have the powder and we have
the liquid now the liquid
um is carbonated so you do need to pop
the tops on them I pop the top on two of
them every night put them in the
refrigerator they're flat in the morning
all all the bubbly's gone
and um I think we've covered
if she needs vitamin D3 we have vitamin
D3 obviously you can take three of those
twice a day
and
um
the sarcoidosis that says Scar Tissue
this is where the MSM is going to help
her also she needs the collagen peptides
as collagen
um from a fish poultry sheep and beef
and she should get two canisters per
month she can take a full dose of
breakfast full dose of dinner time okay
and then you know it gives give us a
call every couple of weeks let us know
how she's doing let us know if she goes
to a doctor and gets some kind of update
but these sorts of things are very
typical
I'm an American who is not supplementing
completely or they are supplementing and
then they're eating gluten and eating
oils and and you know and sort of
interfering with the absorption
utilization of the nutrients because of
the other things they're eating and so
all this needs to be cleaned up and but
these sort of things we can add
25 50 years of people's lives why died
60 when you can live to be 120.
there is one more thing Dr Wallach how
about the nightly Essence now with the
nightly Essence it does have enzymes in
it but when it's not working on food it
turns into a metabolic enzyme which has
been shown to work on Scar Tissue
so nightly enzymes I know pharmacist Ben
recommends that I'm taking two at
bedtime
nightly Essence yeah yeah okay sure
can't hurt
it's a blessing
yes it is well thank you so much Brian
great question thank you for coming on
with us today
and Dr Wallach I'm going to kick you out
of here my friend
nicely of course because it is time for
you to go to your next program and thank
you so much again for all the
information and the time thank you thank
you thank you thank you Rebecca and
thank you team I will see you in a bit
bye-bye all right bye-bye
all right and if I could get my co-host
song with me that would be absolutely
fabulous because I could not do this
without them I have we have our
technical stuff going on we have stuff
in the chat we letting people in we're
making sure that all the cameras are
showing things that we want the world to
see and not embarrass you
and it all takes a team to do it so I am
so grateful for my team we have Marilyn
pazero spear with us today Ruth Ellen
Sanchez and also we have sherry Browning
I could not could not do it without
these lovely ladies I love the fact that
I'm able to surround myself with some
amazing people and folks if you're
looking for a community and want to
surround yourself with some amazing
people then consider joining us with
youngevity youngevity is built of and
this program is sponsored by of course
daily withdoc.com but daily withdoc.com
is a collection of independent
Distributors such as myself and the
ladies that we have here with us and we
just have a heart and passion for people
and making sure that they have knowledge
that is
building the body and not tearing it
down
if you were referred by somebody
specific get back with them and say hey
do you have a team I want to be part of
a team too I want to be able to gain
more information because we have an
amazing health coach program that is
actually presented by The Institute of
holistic health
and
that certified holistic health coach
course goes deep into the four areas of
Health
how they're affected by nutritional
deficiencies and then also Solutions
which is something you don't find with
most health coaching Pro courses
that's one thing that I love the best
about the Institute of holistic health
and as the student services director
it is my honor and privilege to be able
to help people not only find knowledge
but also build successful health coach
businesses so again thank you for
joining us here on daily with Doc
if you want to get a replay of today's
program that will be available in a
couple days on daily withdoc.com but
it's available right after this show on
YouTube look for critical Health news
for the channel Rumble again critical
Health news and on Facebook just like
for critical Health you will find
replays of this program
live
foreign
again thank you so much for joining us
here on daily with Doc my name is Becca
dukes and it is my honor and privilege
to provide this resource to you until
next time
bye for now
[Music]
thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
foreign
thank you
[Music]
[Applause]